we're going to do um our Zen which is
seated
Zen doesn't mean meditation as my
professor correctly pointed out
meditation is something else you have
meditations you have you have
meditations in
um more on the west of SRO the
Greeks early Christianity
actually let's say Middle Ages
Christianity you had meditations that
that purposely involved uh the use of
the intellect and the use of
reason to achieve proximity to the
way you're thinking about something
you're using
reason we use reason all the time it's a
kind of
confirmation uh aspect to your practice
but it's not the bulk of your practice
okay even when the Greeks use reason in
as part of their technology of self it
it was meant in that capacity it's
only as Europe moved into the
Enlightenment and thinkers like dayart
that you had
this prioritization of
reason but originally reason is just a
confirmation exercise so you had
meditations on things what you were
looking for was uh acts of
contradiction uh or hypocrisy because
that measures distance from the way you
can do it here you can't do it there
you're probably not doing it over here
like you thought so for example in the
CQ
set in exercise one
the standing
meditation what do you really know what
do you how what by what means are you
confirming whether yongi is being
internalized through your body and going
to the ground you you have
none I recently shared a post by Mike
Sigman and he's talking about the boat
rowing
exercise we talked about this this
already on
patreon and we pointed out how no one
was doing it like o
Sensei and one of the main differences
is that they would emphasize the forward
movement to the point where the back
foot was
ungrounded whereas o Sensei is
emphasizing the rearward movement
bringing energy y energy down onto the
back
foot and our c set we work with that the
CQ set is a kind
of in the same way that the standing
meditation has really no confirmation
exercise to let you know whether you're
bullshitting yourself or
not the C you set is is the same way
with the boat rowing
exercise if you know how to do it likeo
Sensei it works but if you don't know
what you're doing you're probably going
to yourself yourself to such a
degree that you ultimately change the
form like Terry doson did but 2 feet in
front of his
teacher so in the boat roll exercise
you're learning how to bring yongi onto
the back foot and the grounding the back
foot internalizing grounding but you can
yourself so in our CQ set drills 1
through seven are confirmation exercises
akin to how reasoning Works to spot can
you do it or can you not do it are you
doing it are you not doing it they're
confirmation exercises and your practice
has to be has to have these confirmation
exercises so for
example in drill two where you're
standing in place you're grounding ukas
and energy on the back
foot but you can do that right our
metric for you doing that or not is only
did you get pushed over or not did you
feel muscle tension in you or not do you
see now some muscle tension is visible
that's
obvious and the teacher can spot
that but other muscle tension like your
bicep right your bicep getting tired or
even your mental tension you running a
bunch of thoughts in your
head that is not so visible to the
teacher and it's easily deniable by
you so we go to the next
exercise and the next exercise and
eventually we're on
exercise seven where you don't have a
back foot your feet are side by side
if you were grounding it doesn't matter
that your feet are side by side if the
Yami was being internalized and Vector
down you don't need a back
foot in fact you don't even need
midfoot which eventually we will get
to but if you were doing it wrong all
the way up to seven you can't do seven
you just can't those are confirmation
exercises
and when you can't do seven we realize
you weren't doing drill one you weren't
doing drill two and so on and so on
so reason works like
that but it has the underlying
assumption not doing it here not doing
it there that this is how the old
ancients used reason
if you look at what Sigman was
saying he's going to do the boat rowing
exercise and he is going to use a bag
you see he's going to do a bag to get a
sense of it why because doing it in the
air it's just too easy to
the bag is really no different
from drills
what do we have there three probably
three four five UK is the
bag but we go one further with six and
seven and take away the backf foot
entirely okay those are confirmation
exercises why do you need them because
we'll
ourselves it's interesting I I there was
a recent podcast I'll share it
um but I think it was uh Adam meisner's
teacher that eventually moved away from
the solo
exercises and why because I would say
it's because of this so even here we do
have drill one standing I tell you to do
it I tell you I do it all the
time right I give you time in here to do
it
but most of the time is spent par
exercises because there's less chance of
self-deception
okay that's what's going on
there we're going to do Zen it's not a
meditation and we can sit on the cushion
and be bullshitting
ourselves many many ways okay
so let's get a context for it so you
understand it the
first premise you have to hold is your
practice is away and it must
include these
Stillness
exercises it
must you you can't just do Kona
and you can't be so
naive you know when Stanley pranon was
writing everything on iido
journal and not that he went and
researched everything like anybody else
you kind of just work within your
will and so he had some friends and he
went to his friends and these friends
got published and now these friends are
experts
they'll comment
on East Asian history East Asian
religious culture and now modern
aikidoka read all these guys and think
they know what they're talking
about so there was a there was and still
is a naive statement that they uttered
which is Zen is OS and say was against
Zen and thereby don't do
Z this is just
even any statements uttered by
ensei could equally be
but the distinction of Buddhism
in these kind of strict schools it just
didn't
happen Shinto itself which they would
Advocate or they were advocating
esoteric Buddhism
itself they also had moments of sitting
in
Stillness so to say I don't do Zen
because iido is not Zen you're just full
of you don't know what you're
talking
about your practice must
include silence and Stillness
exercises just like your practice mus
include the four disciplines you cannot
it must include your devotional
practices it must include your action
practices your karma yoga and your Baki
yoga it has to include
it
so the why here's
why these are not psychological
ailments or struggles like we moderns
like to think they
are these are
cosmic
struggles they precede
you they're beyond
you and they will go past
you and you're stuck in the middle
and you will either be a casualty of
those struggles or you can survive those
struggles these struggles to keep it
simple is the struggle
of I
CQ communion and separation fear and
love
the infinite and the
finite the immaterial and the
material
these
forces have energy and
inertia and they will work upon
you you will be taken by them
it's just a matter of
time what the way
is is okay that's my reality that's what
I have to live in exist
in how do I not become a casualty of
it along human history you have all
kinds of ways
that people dealt with
that you had for example your
Satanist they're like I'm going to learn
how to manipulate all this
materiality on the other side you
have what you see in um what Tolstoy
rightly pointed out in that latest book
recommendation you have a pseudo
Christianity that's trying to do
good with
good it's no different than in your iido
right you're going to be you're going to
make yourself super super strong try to
be stronger than everyone and you're
just going to overpower everyone you're
going to Yong Yong Clash all over the
place
see are you going to come over here and
you're going to be this little pacifist
weak sauce person that has some pseudo
morality of
nonviolence in the latest
clip on the good taii essay there's a
part where the aikidoka woman is doing
yill and she says like I can move him
anywhere I can move him here I can move
him there but let's be
nice I'll throw one forward I'll throw
one back as if you could throw people
nice to the
ground that's the same hypocrisy that
tolto is
noting in the pseudo Christianity that
says uh let's go kill for
God in the Christian
armies he had those but you somewhere in
human history in places you have wisdom
which is you know
what there's no way if I play one side
eventually I become the other side and
vice versa so I play the pacifist
nonviolent person eventually I start
throwing people thinking I'm
nonviolent one thing goes to the other
because they're forces they contest each
other and as your one thing you're
fueling the
other there's an inertia to it you've
been taken by
it so the wise said you know I have to
figure out how to not have this
dichotomy that that is the
way using reason people figured out
how to
reconcile the Paradox of
choice and the answer is no
self self gives rise to the
two so in too's book he talks
about Jesus's first commandment is
Thou shalt not resist
evil now left there you're like what the
hell but soon you're going to have to
ask how do I do that cuz at first you're
going to say all
right I guess I just let everything
happen you want to rape me go
ahead and you do you go on and you go on
you
see but it shows trauma in you and
bitterness in you and anger in you and
rage in
you that the gospel doesn't go on to say
hey Jesus a check got it
how it just cuts to the
chase we know what we know about the ego
tripartite mind it it works to reify the
self it constitutes a behavioral
spectrum of Attraction and avoidance
this I want this I don't want everything
you want is everything that's good that
you like you see in air quotes
here so everything you don't want is not
good is
evil this is a confirmation exercise
you're going to do something to me that
at first my ego tripartite mind is going
to measure for good or evil do I like it
do I not like it is it reine myself or
is it not reffin
myself if I have no self you can't do
evil to me
that's the part not in the
gospel it's the same
as if
I have a strong sense of self when you
attack me I feel
attacked when I don't when I release the
self when I reconcile myself when I
deconstruct the ego tripartite mind I
don't experience any of your movement M
as an
attack they're just
movements and I can move freely in
response I don't have a stress
response there's no muscle
tension there's no Will To Power so
there's no yongyong
clashing in budo here we want you to
eventually get to that
level we're going to have you attack you
and see if you can maintain no
self in Jesus he's saying let people do
evil to you see if you can do
it these are confirmation
exercises but we don't start you
there and you can't start there either
with Jesus
you need all these other
exercises sitting still
devotional Karma Yoga all these other
exercises the four disciplines where you
are making micro relases of reconciling
the
self because you're a
beginner don't start at high
stress start at low stress work within
cultivation Fields not application
Fields so when you come to
Zen let's know what we're doing let's
figure out what we're doing you might
not be able to do it just like the
standing meditation or just like cooku
exercise 2
but you have to start there and you
better off trying it than being easily
taken by those Cosmic forces that are
working upon
you while you're not trying
it so the first thing you want to do in
zazen is not make it a
meditation the second thing you want to
do is not make it a relaxation
drone it's not about relaxation it's not
about taking a break from all the
in your life however it may have to
be just like it's better you're doing a
bracing angle in exercise two then
you're on the couch eating your potato
chips watching Netflix or scrolling
through Facebook do you get it you're
better off but it's not
right so you may have been living your
life a certain
way where you come to zazen and you're
like I need a break and you're going to
use it as a break meaning you're in just
no condition to
do the work that needs to be done it's
beyond you the way an attacker would be
Beyond you or the
way do not RK resist evil is beyond you
okay if you're in that case and you're
that way what do you have to do you have
to get your PO disciplines
going if they're not going eventually
you those Cosmic forces are going to
take you you cannot do these
exercises do not justify it by saying oh
Sensei was against then this is stupid
Sensei
so this is very much
like a
prolonged session of the standing
meditation or the standing exercise I
got to stop saying that word is standing
exercise which means there is an
energetic
component so before you start as we did
already I want you to loosen up warm up
okay and I want you to understand some
things I have what I'm going to do just
like in the standing exercise
one is I'm going to allow the nature of
use Cosmic
forces to assist
me using the Chinese
names Heaven
shei by
Design is going to press
down Earth G by Design is going to push
back on
it what I have to
do is
allow my
materiality which is Earth
Chi to not push on it
here but to let it come in to
me so toward that end just like in the
standing I will first work to align
myself so that gravity
is working with me and I am not fighting
gravity I'm going to use
gravity
to begin the non
contesting of Heaven
CH so I align my
body so that I can
relax and that my skeletal alignment can
remain organized
and the
flesh the
tissues can feel
releasable and they will start to
descend do you understand
that your level might be a constant
scanning of muscle flexion just like at
the beginning of the standing exercise
or any of the other CQ exercises
okay
so check your
posture you know where your head goes
your shoulders everything like that okay
so that it can just relax I can release
the skeletal system will remain
organized and I can let all the other
tissues start to drop
okay you may have to do that the whole
time depending where you're at at
because tension will constantly creep in
because you've been living that
way do you understand that meaning
you're going to your your whole zazan
session at the beginning right we
already said at the beginning it might
just be take a break
man but a little bit more it could very
well be you're just going to make sure
your ears and your shoulders and your
chin and the crown of your head and the
and the lumbar region is all in proper
place do you get it Andor combined with
release the tension release the tension
release the tension it just might be
that again you are much better off doing
that than anything else you might be
doing if the world is
taken but once you can do it just like
some of you can do the uh I
C you can't even use
uh because you have that in your body
you can use uh that
experience so for
example you know how someone is going to
come in you know what it feels like they
press on me and drill seven they press
on me and then they go back out they
press on me and it goes back out okay
and you know what that feels like you
can get rid of now the hands up
the movement of the hands you're just
doing it the feeling reexperiencing the
body memory of that
feeling and you can bring that into this
very
posture okay you could do that
too it should feel exactly the same
because it is the
same in then you have mudra
work which is proof positive that it's
not a therapeutic mental thing that it
is energy work otherwise no need for
mudras there's no need for mudra you see
mudras are all
about the
empirical derived value given to this
part of our
hands it's why we have the the movements
in Ika
that move this
energy okay so you have mudra work your
mudra work is also indicative that what
you're trying to do here is reconcile
these two Cosmic
forces you have you're
separating Coq forces in the
thumbs and you have have your adhesion
forces in the
fingers
C
iy and so it should touch that way your
hands should
touch your thumbs should touch with the
same
yongi
rebounding energy so he he pushes on me
you see
and that same Yi descending force is
what's keeping it in place if I go to a
positive y value you'll see the
displacement that is how they
touch you got
it this hand
here touches with the same
adhesion do you understand okay and like
Po and iik in
Kona they work off each other so you you
can't just work
your hands your I key without poke you
and so they feed each other and so you
should feel the
energy of the thumbs making the adhesion
do you understand that but in the
middle you have the
J neither II nor k
so it's not that I
am keeping the
shape I'm doing the internal
work I'm rebounding the energy into my
hands and that shape is kept okay so if
I'm doing this stuff and it gets weak do
you see that which often happens I'm not
doing the internal work I'm probably
just
relaxing okay what if I'm here like this
this is all
external got it just like bracing angle
and drill
Tu so maybe you can get there maybe you
can't if you are not feeling the
internals sleep your hands here you're
working on
releasing you get it releasing the
tissues maintaining the skeletal
organization and releasing the tissues
releasing tissues in fact it's not a bad
idea maybe we'll do it today you're
going to go from you're warming up
you're stretching and loosening getting
ready for what you're doing now letting
go of whatever you were doing okay
starting a new if you had to you you
up last night or all week
starting a new today right now you're
going to warm up and then we'll come
here and you'll just work on the tissue
hanging okay and then
if you're ready you'll come back if at
this point you don't feel ready go right
back to this it's perfectly fine okay
you guys understand that okay so this
the mudra if you can keep it is a
confirmation
exercise so do you see how I did
that you see that that's a different
shape it's a shape that happens because
I just have an external and eventually
one of them's going to give so you have
an external y Yong Clash the universe is
going to harmonize something's going to
go yet okay the tips had to go yet but
if you're
doing this energetically tasking
yourself with this with the same
energetics you will feel a strong pull
and a not attention free pressing in the
thumbs okay do you understand
okay with
this wui state or this D
Jing yin and yang are
reconciled a mind phenomenon happens
your your ego tripartite all your
intellect your consciousness all your
thinking it will
descend and when it descends now there's
no thoughts in your mind you because
it's not you're not rational you're not
doing that you're not that busy mind you
see that it's the same thing in Gaza if
you're doing Gaza your mind's not doing
this your eyes aren't doing this do you
see it's the same thing here in a more
controlled cultivation
field so this is why
they say don't there should be no
thought you don't get no thought by
thinking no thought you only get no
thought by the ego Tri partic mind
descending deconstructing not driving
the bus okay so if you're if you're
feeling your thoughts it's a
confirmation exercise you're you're not
doing the energetic work go back to the
energy
work right the first the beginner stuff
just let the flesh hang let the Mind who
cares you're thinking right but think
about skeletal organization tissue
dropping
okay any questions on
this okay make sure you you have a good
base um because we're using
gravity and not I I
myself am not a strong advocate of
laying
down there's doesn't work as well okay
not for
beginners
um the more unstable your base is your
body doesn't want to let go because of
the fear of
falling
okay um so make sure you're
stable um uh Lotus half
Lotus
cesa pretty good okay but they go
down they go down in uh in
stability okay seated if you have
to uh but it's not so easy okay there's
also things you're doing with your legs
that happens in Lotus and half Lotus it
doesn't happen in
Sea um we know from our training that
the legs are freaking hard to get to
release okay and again if we understand
these as Cosmic
forces and not like psychological
theories um the crossing of the legs
leads to a kind
of uh anatomical
confusion to the ego tripartite mind and
it kind of just goes it okay so
what I mean by this is as you as you
cross parts of your body uh your mind
has a difficult
time understanding right and left for
example you see and as it has that
difficult time understanding that it's
more likely to just let go of it even
incorrectly so it might go uh like for
right now to be honest I'm not I I have
to think about it to to know which foot
was that because I've been in that in
the half Lotus for a while now okay that
happens you have a lot of exercises
where you do this with your hands you
see you do stuff like this and you will
eventually I don't know which fingers
are right and which fing deserve left
sometimes there's even kids games so
there's pictures of all sensei in these
mudas but there were kids games right
you remember those and you would go uh
move you have your friend do this or you
have your friend do this right and you
go move that finger and they move a
different finger you see that's what's
happening here and you don't quite get
that in sea but you do get the releasing
part of it okay and as you go uh into
see seated it more more that goes away
but it's not necessary it's just helpful
okay if you are seated make sure your
feet are on the ground so that you have
that sense of security okay any
questions or comments on
Zan all right so let's we'll warm up a
little loosen up cuz you've been
sitting let go of the day we're here
it's day one this is what you're doing
and then we'll go into this one okay and
then we'll go into uh this one okay so
I'll ring the bell that's when you go on
your cushion and you'll go to this one
and then I'll ring the bell in a little
while after that and you'll try to form
the mudra energetically if not stay
where you are you could try it and go
back to it okay many a day I just do
this one
okay oh yeah I should add burmes is is
good too burmes as a seated posture
that's
good
um all right so what if if you get there
and what you're doing then in the end is
energetic
work it's mudra work okay you're going
to let the mudra you work the mudra
okay you don't try to not think you
don't try to relax you don't try to
concentrate you work the mudra and the
mudra
concentrically pulls that ego tripartite
mind down and apart okay you guys
understand so that's what you're doing
here this is also why it's placed at the
lower tonden
level the mudra pulls the Mind down okay
when the mind gets down there it has
these two forces
reconciled with that neither nor state
in between and you just work the
mudra no more thinking no more
concentrating no more talking no more
relaxing it's energetic mudra work okay
do you guys understand I okay how do you
work it same way you work it with the UK
same exact way it's the same exact thing
okay any questions or comments or
observations yes um I felt
that um I was acquiring tension in my
shoulder and at that same time I was the
feeling like I was losing the iy in yeah
at that point I tried to release that I
couldn't feel that the cusion so I yes
and that's what your teacher said to do
okay so you're feeling tension in there
it'll show up in the in the mudra work
because the mudra is formed
energetically just like if he's if he's
pushing at me you see and you feel that
you see uh you're not at the energetic
level that whereas you're here like this
or he's pushing really hard and I'm not
affected by this at all it's not in
my musculature so to speak do you see uh
and so my voice doesn't doesn't change
my movement doesn't change or anything
like that it shows up in the mutra okay
so with if you you go to here and now
you're trying to Mud your work and
you're like no it's not freaking working
go back to the other one okay so for
example if you're trying to do drill
seven of the coke you set and you're
constantly beinging projected you know
off you can't do the drill should you
keep trying to do drill seven no no go
back to drill one drill two now try to
do them with the failure awareness and
the failure points of seven in my but
you go back to drill one or two so same
thing here once you realize it's not
there it could also be as I told you I
can't stop thinking okay it's not there
then because the mind is up here the
mind is not down here so go back to the
other one which is basically drill one
do you see go back to drill one and just
let the tissues fall okay let the
tissues fall now you might be in such a
state I can't okay but you're now not
eating chips and scrolling through
Facebook so you're better off go back
then to the Bedrock practices and the
four disciplines get going okay uh and
that's how you work this as a practice
as a
way there is much better to do what you
did go back to this because one you're
doing what your teacher said which is
your Baki yoga okay and two uh you're
not deceiving yourself with this
of I'm doing zazen and you're
like thinking or relaxing or doing mind
filling stuff okay so you have more yes
um how do you when you're and how do you
process pain in the body so pain is a
material thing it's a thing of Yin it's
a thing
of fear okay and when the self is
released it's going to sound weird but
there's no pain right the body does not
feel the
pain um
and that too is a sign of whether you're
able to release the self or not okay so
you guys know um that I've been battling
this kind of back thing that's been
there for a while but you also know once
I get on the mat and someone touches me
and I'm doing my stuff there's no sign
of it so all those videos we've been
doing there's no sign of it you see
because once we're pairing we're doing
the energetic work I'm in a no sell
State I don't feel the pain okay you
also know that recently we've been
forgoing
Zen uh because we have this is hard to
me zazen like the standing
exercise they're foundational doesn't
mean that they're the easiest ones to do
they're the hardest ones to
do why because you can so
easily Okay so we've been forgoing that
even
skipping not spending much time on the
standing exercise drill one and working
drill right 2 three 4 we're working at
the at the other drills where there's
more confirmation okay so last last
Saturday we dedicated to you and it was
way
confirmation high do do you see that
okay so but my own pra my own body mind
is like I'm running out of time and
I can't do my work so
today uh this whole week the injury's
been so bad I think you saw me the other
day when I couldn't even really walk
after
class that I'm like we're doing Zen
today so I put myself here okay and then
my teacher responsibilities were that I
put it on tape okay so here I am I have
a pain response I recognize it as a yiny
block of Heaven sheet it's a materiality
emphasis it's a a
matter um inertia that I'm caught in and
so I'm going to come to the hardest
drill and release that and so I don't
have the pain right now so same thing if
there's a pain in my knee or a pain in
my foot if you go to the nose self the
pain just stops it doesn't necessarily
mean the injury is gone but the pain
signaling definitely stops okay and you
can use that as well so let's say you're
in your
posture and um the PO you can't separate
the self from what you're doing right
right now then same way as I would go to
a less stress inducing environment okay
so I can't sit in Sea all right do
standing do you see you get what I'm
saying I can't stand for 40 minutes okay
don't stand for 40 minutes stand for 20
minutes do do you see what I'm saying
just like this is to this is beyond my
skill level because my what I'm doing
here is the energetic aspect of release
okay because release is a skill if I
can't do it at this level then simplify
your environment and take more stress
out likewise at the higher budo levels
you attack you do you see that if we
failing right away and all it's
producing is self- reification and self
attachment don't do that do something
where it's not doing that what do I do
simplify and d-stress the environment
okay because complication and stress is
the trigger of self why because it's
fear you see it's fear uh it's that
cosmic energy okay non non- contestation
why I say it's a skill and it's a skill
it's the skill of release uh is just
getting these energetic forces in order
so that I'm not subject
to even good or bad I'm not subject to
them
okay um too many times we think it's a
psychological thing and hence we could
think about non- contestation you see or
we could think about
self-release and feel that we're going
to be able to do it in the world right
not just in Z but we're going to do it
no you're not going to be be
able to okay because the thinking is the
self that is contesting the seed of
contestation is the self so you can't do
it thinking you have to do it
energetically okay that's your bridge
between spirit and body the energetics
zazan is energetic work thereby don't do
an environment that you can't get rid of
thinking that it's not going to work
okay and environments that are
complicated or you experience as highly
stressful you're not going to release in
those environments you're going to
attach in those environments which is
why we use those environments for
Advanced Training you see we want to see
we know that environment is going to
trigger self attachment let's see if you
can hold
self-release that's this only purpose
okay so feeling that just come back come
back right how far back oh like I said
you might have to go back to your
Bedrock practices and your for
disciplines which you should always be
doing
okay all right any other questions or
comments okay so uh just as I'm managing
in the mudra the C you an I
key here I'm doing the same okay so
there's the I key in the grip which I
always say there's the iys right here
just like my hands right here in the
mudra and there's a Coq too and you're
pushing on me do you see that I can't
just
do can't do that okay so it's your
special day because we're you have all
that tension in you okay so
I doesn't matter as I said it doesn't
matter how I stand I don't have to stand
in shenai and I don't have to sit in
zazen um and we don't want to these are
cultivation Fields uh eventually I want
to be able to move and still get the C
do you understand that okay
so just cuz I'm in Han me nothing
changes okay we simplify it cuz I'm on
one foot the back foot
and I make sure that I feel the adhesion
make sure you feel that that's why
sometimes I tell you don't close your
rib to because I can tell that none of
you are feeling the adhesion you're
contesting at the Palm okay so that's
why I have you uh so if you push you see
we're not going anywhere I'll take it
off and you'll see that you can start
slippering you see so I have to match
that okay and it doesn't matter cuz your
hands are closed I don't take advantage
of you holding me I match the Palm okay
so you you even lightened it a little
and you can see that I kind of pressed
into it to get that equal uh uh y value
okay and then everything releases in my
body just like in Zen it starting to
slip so I'm going to add it okay there
it is again okay got it all right now
something happened here which is very
common you're suffering from contagion
so stay there please don't just don't do
anything different don't do anything
different and let go of
me and let's see how good you guys are I
said he's suffering from
contagion what should have
happened if he didn't do anything
different and he let go of me he should
have come forward because he's finally
displacing Okay so UK has a
role this okay but as you felt me
released You released okay so don't do
that you're in you're in
your you get you don't want to be Jedi
Mind trickable okay so you're here you
should be here okay even though you felt
me relaxed you don't relax okay so
that's what I'm feeling and now you're a
triggering aspect do you see but you're
also young
aspect that if I get triggered I will
block out you see I'll do this tension
in my body and I don't want to do that
you're young I don't contest it at the
surface of my body I let it go in and
I'm working the mudra here okay this is
both iy and you were not coming forward
C you okay and I work the same energy
work just like before you'll feel the
tanden you should feel the tanden fill
you'll feel the Mind drop and the
tension goes away all pain goes away and
because of how I've cast myself the back
midfoot should feel as if it's
compressing down like someone is
stepping on my foot is what it feels
like and you
push and I can just keep releasing
releasing the same exact way as in
Zen I'll feel my tissues drop in other
words I'll feel my mind you went
contagion again and you're fatiguing
right which you can tell like that
should happen because you're working and
I'm not working okay but that's what
we're trying to do so let's get this
closer to zazen work and SS then work
closer to this work okay all right let's
try
it okay so first you take all your Yin
all your
materiality and it
drops onto the back
midfoot okay not the back heel so you're
too
straight because the midot forward of
the heel you're going to have to can a
little okay got it does everyone
understand that
so
M here's my midfoot on that cross
there
okay got it
okay and I'm going to shift my body
straight on back like this and I'm
standing up do do you guys see that my
weight is on my
heel okay to put it on the
midfoot I have to bring my body forward
do you see that okay now a lot of time
and you're thinking this you're
thinking come off the front
foot and now you're over this foot do
you see that okay and the front foot
weighted but I'm not midfoot weighted
okay so I have to go into the midfoot
here here's coming off the front foot
you see
that you're going to push and I'm going
to feel it in my heel okay and I'm going
to need some tension here to keep that
heel we here got it now I look like you
I do come off the front foot but that's
not what I told you I want you to put
your weight on the
midfoot okay so weights on the midfoot
and you can see that can now I'm going
to go back to your
posture so I sit up
straight and I'm on the heel you get
that okay now if I just
relax I'm going to fall at this back
diagonal cuz it's on my heel if you pay
attention here I am when you push that's
what I'm fighting I have to fight you're
going to pay attention you're like
trying to keep this Integrity here okay
so start with the
exercise midfoot and this is the
beginning of the rowing you see the
beginning of the rowing right the rowing
exercise it goes on to the midfoot so
we're like simplify this just put your
own weight on the
midfoot and then we'll test are you
midfoot or
not do you understand that that's all
we're doing okay so here we go we start
with you
first and your forget about UK your
exercise is to get all your weight
right
there just put your own weight
there
okay not get it off your heel more there
you
go let it just sink all your tissues
drop on it everything drops just like in
saw
everything let it release
let this arm release to that midfoot
too it brings you up it brought you
up
there coku in the grip II in the
palm and then the Yang energy you let
follow your own materiality onto that
foot okay
don't every time you inhale you lose the
C you okay and this is one reason
why it's not right the the literal
translation of cooku is breath however
breath to the Ancients dides not mean
what we mean by breath okay so that's
why I don't want you to change anything
than the physical instructions right now
okay don't do what all modern tells you
so just
breathe no don't breathe if it's going
to change the physical instructions do
you see hold hold your freaking breath
if you have to breathe more shallow
don't go abdominal breathing don't go
peaceful thoughts don't do anything okay
the the Y forces is trying to get in
you're going to let it in by removing
your Chi obstacle the chi the Earth Chi
is contesting the yangqi the Demonic is
contesting right now with the Divine
okay so get your weight
there onto that foot under that spot
okay get off your
heel and let it
release and you got to get rid of all
this tension all this is supposed to
draw
it's
still
here here so if I was going to throw you
and I wanted to get over the edge of
your foot I'd have to bring you this way
you see okay you're way back
here so
get
there let all this drop
there then lift your hand which is going
to push on the heaven she so you should
feel even more weight on that foot with
your own
hand form L the
mudra and now I follow your Yin
keep this
organization don't let your shoulders
move oh come
on just keep it is what I said I didn't
say do something okay you're still
leaning back on
me bend your knees more there you
go stay there stay
there stay there stay in this state just
like zazen stay in this state keep your
hand exactly where it is don't let it go
left or right in or
out neither push nor pull
neither resist nor
overcome stay there
don't change
anything don't let your shoulder go back
that would change
[Music]
something stay exactly like this even
though I'm going to change your mind
feel my palm more with your wrist there
you go I just said feel it more and
don't move into
me that would change your arm position
just feel it more bring your mind to
where my Palms on your
wrist
good there you go that's the I
key bring your mind more to your hand
not going towards your body good there's
the C you stay in this
state and and here is here is your limit
right here
okay and what I mean by this this is as
much Yi as you able to
reconcile okay or
non-contest okay cuz if I start going a
little bit more the attention came back
see that you put your hand out okay so
this would be going back to yours we go
harder it's going to trigger him more
he's going to contest more and all we're
practicing is
contestation okay so you would hang out
there okay and we'll do that now so um
and one reason why this is level two the
only thing to do from here is go to
level one but level one allows for so
much bullshitting don't go to level one
okay go to go to level two and have your
experien Senpai C that if I go past this
I can feel your self contest yet okay
got it okay so we'll try that go R and
you go with Sean please don't push him
into so all right so we're in the
question comment phase you can sit down
I was saying I feel my C yeah it starts
to light up and just burn as if I'm
still exerting so as as you descend in
your
body uh just like as remember these are
I I say these are cosmic forces okay
they're just C they're just aspects of
the universe it's just it is what it is
okay um your materiality your matter is
Yin it's that
fear force is what you but and again
it's not fear in the sense of uh you
know psychoanalytical fear that you got
to think broader it's Cosmic okay it's
the separation Force you see separating
against what against the Divine Force
that's what it is okay so your your
materiality is more of that separating
Force okay and its instinct is to
contest this is why uh it contests what
the Divine State what is the Divine
State no self to see okay so this is why
we can use
violence against the flesh
triggers that protection that
contestation act you see and so if you
are skilled at no self no violence is
going to trigger you the same way
pain right pain pain and uh
architectural functionability are
entirely different you might break my
arm if I can release self I won't feel
the pain of it my arm won't work do you
guys understand that okay so your
materiality is part of that what's on
the other
side and as it goes down the body it is
stronger in its opposition this is why
the yin the opposing is From Below got
it well my feet are below my lower legs
are below my glutes are below do you
understand and hence this is why this
tissue really houses all your fear have
you ever done this have you ever been
driving and you hit some turn and you're
like whoa I'm going you feel like I'm
going out of the lane or or or maybe any
other kind of driving whoo moment you'll
flex your legs your legs have nothing
nothing to do with what we're doing
right now you see they're not they not
Fred Flintstone and they're going to
control the car but it goes into my legs
as well okay uh if you haven't
experienced that check it out notice it
next time like I'm flexing my other leg
for no freaking reason this this is
where fear is is the strongest okay uh
and if you paid attention while your
calf is burning probably your feet are
clenching too you your feet will clench
okay a thing we've been working on with
you do youc um so yeah that is much
harder to do it's much harder to
do and that's why you do it and it's
it's a skill so you can't go got it
today and it's gone
no as we already said depending on your
skill at the four disciplines and the
Bedrock practices your ability to
release is infringe upon so f up there
you're probably going to do this
right maybe last week you lived better
meaning you lived in accordance with
your teacher's teaching and Zen wasn't
so big a deal but this week you liveed
like you veered from your teacher
teaching and now I can't I can't do this
you see it could have been the C drill
set last time I got to drill 7 no
problem this time I can't get past drill
one you see that or last time I spared
okay this time I was triggered as
hell I was contesting and Yong Yong
clashing all over the place it's a skill
okay um so we'll get you get there but
get there means that you're living the
right way so that you can do this okay
and the more you can do it in situations
and environments to the contrary the
more skilled you are do you guys
understand that so we
had um in that last one with
you it's much better it's a much uh more
trying environment than Federation Ikea
so for example you stand up okay and I'm
I'm the
ferite okay and this is what I do you
see so there's no y aspect to what I'm
doing and then you know whatever you do
do what
ever I'm going to go wherever do you see
so you can practice in your mind non-c
contestation you
see but it's so an unchallenging
situation environment that whatever
non-c contestation you did it's at such
a lowlevel skill that it's not practical
do you get what I'm saying okay so you
were here and while not sparring you see
it was more challenging than
fedorite UK me for me you see as UK you
got it and so we worked at that level
and then as you get better we work at
higher levels higher levels higher
levels what are higher levels situations
and environments in which that skill is
more difficult to hold because they
promote self reification how by
threatening your materiality by
threatening yourself you got it if you
look at your resistance to your
teacher's teaching it's all because it's
threatening to yourself that's why you
do it right um take tollo thing why did
the church produce a pseudo Christianity
because no matter how simple Jesus's
teaching was it was threatening to the
self it could not do it you see well
likewise you know the four disciplines
you know the Bedrock practices why can't
you do them because it's threatening to
the C we don't do it okay same thing
here I'm you know how you could put if I
took everything out and I just said hey
put your weight on the
midfoot can you do it just put your
weight on that mid fooot put it on the
midot get off your heel he put it on the
mid
foot get off your
heel good keep
going keep
going and you
see he has the C straighten your
back straighten your back like you
were and now shift your weight from foot
to
foot and where do you feel more more on
the heel okay do you got do you
understand that okay
so again we think it's innocent I'm
telling you it's
Cosmic if the way comes to you and tells
you don't do
that until you can release you will do
that why because the way told you not to
do it this this is
why what you do is always going to be
degrees to what you were told to do
always it's not going to ever be
45 you see you could have been for
example in the
arch but you go towards the back of the
foot why because the way told you come
to the front of the foot I'm telling you
so this is more for
me more a sign of on that we're not
dealing with fium psychoanalytical
Concepts and modern psychology Concepts
there's Cosmic forces here you will
always push back resist contest 180 to
what you should not be doing okay so
when you take for example going back to
Tolstoy and you he rightly pulls
out the virtue of Integrity from the
teachings of Jesus
you should not
swear don't swear an oath on anything
because your word should be enough
because you have consistency between
thought speech and action that's how we
say that do you
see so don't make a
oath and what does the Demonic
do swear on this swear on what on the
words of Jesus Christ swear on on the
words that told you not to swear then
you'll do what you say it could have
been anything else but it could it can't
be because of the cosmic makeup of the
universe right we could have said swear
on this lucky statute swear on this uh
on the Constitution but we don't because
the Constitution didn't say that Jesus
Christ said that and it I got I'm on the
other side of that you see and so I make
a mockery of what it is that's what
happens all the time that's what happens
in iiko all the time that is why iido is
180 not 45 modern iido is
180 opposite of what you're supposed to
be